[Music]
I've seen solo a Star Wars story and I
have thoughts this is a spoiler free
review and it's gonna go a little all
over the place because to be totally
honest I have mixed feelings about the
movie I went in expecting this
completely familiar kind of nostalgic
feel kind of a summer flick but this
movie has an unexpectedly bold adventure
that reaches depths of the Star Wars
galaxy I never thought imaginable on the
big screen exploring young Han Solo to
me was a gutsy move this character has
never carried his own movie and you're
giving it to a brand-new young actor now
much like the other anthology Star Wars
movie rogue one solo is not about the
Jedi thus if the force or lightsabers it
doesn't have an opening crawl it's not
scored by John Williams and you have
three new actors portraying three
beloved characters we've known most of
if not our entire lives these aren't
necessarily negative criticisms but it's
worth noting why it might take a hot
minute to adjust to the fact that you
are watching a Star Wars movie it took
me about 30 minutes or so to feel like
solo it found its footing and that's
right around the time that Lando
Calrissian comes into play but once it
gets going it makes the jump to
Lightspeed and it does not slow down
there was a lot of talk a
behind-the-scenes drama legendary
screenwriter lawrence kasdan who wrote
The Empire Strikes Back Return of the
Jedi and the force awakens teamed up
with a son John Kasdan to penned the
flick and Ron Howard who was in George
Lucas pre Star Wars movie American
Graffiti by the way 1973 stepped into
direct late in the game after Phil Lord
and Christopher Miller departed over
creative differences and you might see
people saying that they picked this up
on screen but I I truly didn't notice
plus the combo of Howard and Kasim kind
of brings a sense sense of warmth to the
movie much like Han Solo himself this
movie isn't without flaws but none of
those flaws stem from Alden Ehrenreich
spur trail of the iconic smuggler I
never doubted this guy always loved him
but there were reports he had to have an
acting coach on set and fans were
panicking but know this dude has all the
roguish charm that makes up Han Solo
without doing a single impersonation of
Harrison Ford's rather impressive you
probably expected this one but Donnell
Glover's take on the suave Lando
Calrissian and his many capes is a
scene-stealer through and through in
fact some of the biggest laps for me in
a Star Wars movie to date came courtesy
of Lando and his overtly sassy Droid and
co-pilot l 3-3-7 played by Phoebe Waller
bridge she really goes there
now the newcomers all bring something to
the table but the heart of solo was
completely about Han and Chewie the
budding relationship we get to see these
two meet for the first time and lay down
the foundation of what brought them
together as co-pilots and BFFs and
you've got a tip your hat to Jonas to
otama and Alden Ehrenreich seamless
chemistry now Jonas kind of discreetly
snuck into the Star Wars franchise to
take on some more action intensive
scenes for Peter Mayhew
in the force awakens and has since kind
of quietly taken over the reins as
Chewbacca almost entirely and they're
finally starting to bring him to the
forefront and I just really enjoyed his
performance in this movie I think he's
so fantastic anyway as I mentioned Solo
goes some unexpected places for better
and for worse when you bring together a
young Han Chewie and Lando I expect
these well known kind of nostalgic feats
like the Kessel run
Chuy's life-debt han winning over the
Falcon from Lando and some of these
things happen some don't but the ones
they do tell are in very surprising ways
like you may assume tell things happened
and went down in your head Cannon and
it's not that way at all it brings
surprising new facets to these legendary
tales while throwing in brand new
concepts and characters and some big
surprises that tie in the Star Wars lore
as a whole together in a very daring way
I wasn't terribly worried about spoilers
ahead of solo but having seen it I urge
you to avoid them at all costs solo is
gonna challenge viewers to dive deeper
into the mythos of Star Wars and it will
be very interesting to see how these
gutsier moments are received among
general audiences and whether or not
diehard fans are on board with the
direction the possible saga could take I
found it a little bold for the big
screen but we'll see I'm still
processing we're gonna dive deeper into
spoilers after release there's so much
unpacking so much that I want to openly
talk about but we have to wait at the
end of the day though solo is a fun
movie you're gonna have a smile on your
face gonna have a really good time and
of course you can tweet me any
spoiler-free questions you have I'm
happy to answer them as long as they're
spoiler free you can see solo on May
25th
may the force be with you
[Applause]